-Our first guest is
a Golden Globe winner
for his fantastic work
on the popular
television series
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
He now stars in
the critically acclaimed
new film "Palm Springs."
You have to check out.
You can see it on Hulu and
at select drive-ins right now.
Here is Andy Samberg.
Andy!
-Yes.
-Come on.
Finally. I can feel that.
I can feel you.
-Jim-Jam Jones.
-Oh.
-Ahhhh.
-Thank you so much
for doing my show.
I appreciate it, buddy.
You look great.
-Yeah.
You, too.
-Thank you, man.
-I've got my headphones.
-Is that what you use
for the Zooming?
-Yeah.
Well, you know what I say.
The only Air Bud I like
is the dog in the movie.
-Stop, stop, stop.
[ Both laugh ]
-I don't have any.
-"There's nothing
in the rule book
that says a dog
can't play basketball."
[ Both laugh ]
I take his jokes.
Are you been --
Have you been binge-watching
the shows
and watching things
and watching television?
What are you up to?
What are you watching?
-Yeah.
You know what
we actually binge-watched,
finally, was "Mad Men."
I had never seen it.
[ Laughs ]
-The show with Jon Hamm?
-Yeah.
Yeah, the one with Hamm,
our friend.
[ Both laugh ]
-Never saw "Mad Men"?
-Never saw it.
-I saw --
You know what, I miss --
There's a space that I missed.
But I saw the beginning
and the end.
-Oh, you skipped
the middle part?
-Kinda did a little bit, maybe
-You mostly got it.
-But I kind of get it, right
Wait.
-It's very good.
-It's fantastic, right?
-Yeah.
It's, like, one of the
best shows ever made, almost
[ Both laugh ]
-I totally agree.
It was beautifully shot.
-Yeah.
-The acting was off the charts
The writing was great.
-Truly compelling stuff.
-Does Hamm know that we --
neither of us have seen
the complete show?
You're pretty good friends
with him, right?
-I've been friendly with him
for a long time,
and it's never come up.
-Yeah.
I don't think it's come up
with me, either.
I guess, why would you do that
You'd be like, "Hey.
Do you watch my show?"
-Yeah.
But it is weird 'cause, like
he hosted "SNL" at least twice
while I was there,
maybe three times.
We did a bunch
of "Mad Men" sketches.
I did, like, a "Mad Men" spoof
on the Emmys when I hosted it.
Like, I definitely have been
living in plain sight
as a person acting like
they've seen "Mad Men."
[ Laughs ]
-But I'm so glad you saw it.
It is --
It is really unbelievable.
-It is, yeah.
-I loved it.
I loved it so much.
Are you -- Are you --
Your kid is not old enough
to go to camp, right?
No camp.
Cancelled, right?
-No, she's 3.
3, yeah.
-We should start, like,
a 3-year-old camp thing
for 3-year-olds.
But now's not the time
to start it, probably.
-Maybe one
where they, like, build robots
-Yeah.
Is your kid into robots?
-She is.
But I'm more just --
I'm thinking it'd be a, like
a cheap way
to get some robots going.
-People love robots.
You know, we've done --
I think a lot of our cameras
are robots here.
-Yeah.
Wait. Really?
-Yeah, they really are.
We have to cut back on everyon
who's in the studio and stuff.
So, it's, like,
remote-controlled -- yeah.
We sent you a remote control
Do you want to just see
if you want to zoom in
or move it around?
-Sure. Yeah, let's do it.
-Yeah.
You can do it from your house.
Go.
[ Clears throat ]
-Wow, look at that.
-Oh, you quick --
Was a fast zoom.
All right.
We're good.
-Yeah.
Mine's working, too.
You can zoom out a little bit.
I mean, I am --
I'm 45.
-You wearing makeup, buddy
-Little bit.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-You saw it?
[ Chuckles ]
-Tell you what, I'm not wearin
air buds, and I'll tell you why.
-What?
Oh, yeah.
That's true,
you're not wearing air buds.
-Well, it's 'cause the onl
Air Bud that I like --
-No, no.
We already heard that.
-Did I do it already?
-Yeah.
It was good the first time, too.
What are these called?
These are just headphones?
-These are just -- yeah.
-They don't have a cool name
-These are land buds.
[ Both laugh ]
-Dude, digging
your land buds, dude.
Pretty cool.
-Thanks, yeah.
I just went
with the old-school land buds.
[ Both laugh ]
-I want to get into --
-Me and you
are kind of land buds,
'cause we live on land,
and we're buds.
-That's right.
We've been land buds
for a long time now,
we've been land buds.
-It's true.
-Did I read somewhere that
you enjoy going to weddings?
-I do love --
I love going to weddings.
-Really?
-I do.
I've seen you at a wedding
-Yeah.
Was I fun at the wedding?
We went golfing.
-Oh, that's right.
[ Laughing ]
-And there was a giveaway --
there was a giveaway
near where we were staying
for a Porsche, I think.
And there was, like,
a Porsche sitting there.
-Dude, yes.
-And I've a sweet pic of you -
We took --
We're still children.
We took pictures of each other
posing in front of the Porsche
like, low down, like,
"Hey, it's me with a Porsche!"
-It's the best --
Oh, that's right.
That was a great photo.
Yeah, I --
I haven't been to a weddin
probably since then.
I mean, I think I have fun
I mean,
why do you like weddings?
-I like -- Well, open bar.
-Yeah.
-Right?
-That's true. That's true.
Yep.
-Free food.
-Yeah.
-Always pretty slammin' grub
And then, everyone's dancing
-Yeah.
-Like, I feel as an adult,
there's not a lot
of opportunities to dance.
Right?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
I don't really go to clubs
-That's what I'm saying.
-Yeah.
-It's old guy at the club.
Like, you can't go to the clubs.
-I can't go to the clubs
anymore, man.
Oh, so a wedding is almost lik
going to the club.
-It's like -- It's like
the club for adults.
-Yeah. I kind of see
where you're going with that
And you're like "Hey, this
is what -- they invited me
I gotta do what I have to do."
-You're almost being a jer
if you don't dance at a wedding.
-Weirdly, a Jon Hamm story
we were at the Emmy party
that we had in L.A.
And he goes, "Hey, do you want
to get this party going?"
I was, like,
"Yeah, let's do it."
He goes, "All right.
Come on,
let's get on the table."
And we stood on a table
and started dancing.
-And did it set it off?
-Yes.
It did.
-[ Laughs ]
-Totally set it off.
It was unbelievable
and unforgettable.
And I'll never forget that
He saved the party.
Everyone was --
-Do you remember --
Do you remember
what song was playing?
-It wasn't anything
that amazing.
It was almost weird that we were
on the table for this song
And we just got up,
and it was, like --
People are like, "Whoa, I gues
there's no rules at this party."
-Yeah.
It was hallelujah.
It was like, "Finally."
And then -- pwkk! --
everyone just started, like...
-No, no.
I meant the song.
-Oh.
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, I thought you meant
it was the reaction
from people at the party,
like -- [ Vocalizing ]
-Yeah. It was Leonard Cohe
doing "Hallelujah."
-I want to talk about
"Palm Springs," 'cause, dude
I loved it so much, and I can'
wait to talk to you about it
We'll dissect
every single scene.
Is that okay?
-Yeah. Come on.
-More with Andy Samberg
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.